how much pressure is on the Indians
tonight Shawn oh this is a lot of
pressure because uh you know it's a
treat that 32 they got a face Arrieta
you know you you know really want to go
to a game seven being on 31 so I think
there's some D's amount of pressure it's
hello and you know out here in Cleveland
damage please just uh rockin to everyone
talks about Chicago and and you know
Wrigley was was rocking but in all the
history tab there's a lot of history
here to of know it's a big job for the
Indians and this piece excited that came
stickers in Cleveland make it clinch it
here at home what kind of weather we
expecting tonight it looks like it's
gonna be like 73 and sunny I'm gonna be
sunbathing in the stance nice i like
that i like that Sean will be nice
shawna be part of the MLB network's live
coverage from Cleveland that starts at
three today immediately following the
conclusion of tonight's game as well the
pitching matchup Arrieta seemed to
struggle at the end of the year and I
thought he kind of got out of jams the
last time around what do you expect with
his pitching matchup tonight I was a lot
colder in Game two here in Cleveland and
you know I feel like I feel like when
you watch Arrieta in when you watch them
in Game two he was effect effectively
wild you know yet yeah I think he had a
note survivor ya know yeah so I mean he
was effectively wild got in some trouble
couple walks and there but was able to
pitch out of it we still have great
stuff you know if you go back look at
the game to miss with a couple pictures
that just um yeah the Indians fouled
back or whatever just because he has
good late moving them is oh so you know
you expect him to do better than I he
didn't have a great feel on his pitches
because it was cold out and I think with
the weather being really good tonight
you know email probably have a better
feel when Chapman was on the mound the
other night that's where you can almost
see fear in a batter's eyes or at least
the helplessness do you remember that
feeling at the plate where there was
just one picture where you went I just
have no chance here um I never felt like
I had no chance but oh yeah you know
what I did wrong on no chest the first
time I faced Randy
Johnson was kind of that Chapman feeling
like wow that's different you know be
like that's a hundred what's uh you know
with a not 21 hours slider like you know
I think I first got to the big leagues
that was the first time I was like
that's different you know and I when I
look at scatman I look at Sam and I and
I think of I think of that you know
Randy Johnson just forgot big lefty you
know has that downward tilt could be so
big he's real real lanky and you know
but every face god I think one thing
know about Chapman though if I if I ever
did faze them you know you've got that
straight four seam fastball so as I hear
you know these guys are big league
hitters too then and I think eventually
the more you see that fastball you know
the more you can it's good no I'm not
it's tough to get on 102 103 but I was
saying you do have a chance after you
see him a few times that's why I was
think man if you can get Chapman early
in that first or second pitch because
you really don't want to get to that
slider and he's starting to throw it
more so you know he dominated the other
night that was a really rolled right
through that it was it was smart by bad
too premature eight outs how long have
you known Terry Francona command on Tito
a long time you know back to back to
when I first broke into the big leagues
when he was at the Phillies and you know
Brad Mills to was his bench coach
standard and uh an implant for him in
2008 you know as we always had a mutual
admiration for judges were both from
Pittsburgh growing up and uh and you
know that I played with him two thousand
eight days he's one of a kind absolutely
one of a kind burst Valley in the game
what what's your favorite story ah you
know what um you know he's uh he's just
a funny dude and uh in two thousand
eight when I was with Boston you know
when you hit the bump the monster
sometimes you don't know like you know
you can make it a second delighted for
me it was always an adventure so you
know he wasn't upset on time I'm going a
second I get thrown out up from the
monster right oh my gosh not that big it
feel like left-field the guy got me
excited nobody'll then so my next to bat
I hit a missile man right-center gap
right and not nothing less than a right
there bullet me
gab it ends up hit the top of the
sentence so I'm like I thought was a
homer but I wasn't like Pippin or
anything i was i was still running you
know teasing you know works for me
decent like not good slow so i rounded
first my glass to homer hits the top of
the fence and nick markakis goes into
the gap for the Orioles and he bare
hands it off the wall except ounces back
to a parent off the wall comes and
roping and I'm just like you know don't
as quick as I can oh my gosh he gets
thrown out from rights area so i still i
did i'm not there like 10 feet like it
was feeling like that and the crowds
like the crowd booing me and I'm like
all medicines this Tiger so I didn't I
god oh my god like I throw it out right
there so I go to put my I gonna put my
helmet away at titos life hey case can I
talk to you I'm like yeah man what's up
he's like listen he's like I think you
might want to check some out I don't
know do you think you might have polio I
was like oh my god you know what I
didn't never stop that but maybe I might
need to check that out about that I've
never been throwing up a right Jennifer
for ya haven't you been thrown out from
every position yeah how doesn't to go my
goal when I was in the business you know
when I got thrown out from left and 2006
when I was with the Red Sox no way I
knew it was my last year so I said if I
could just get thrown off the
right-center expand way no it will run
the gamut so who wins tonight I think
that I figured I think we're going to
seven I really do and I think we're
going Sam and I just you know it's been
that it's been that back and forth
series I think Arrieta comes out tonight
picks as well and you know I think tom
is going to pitch well too but i think
that the Cubs are going to find a way to
win it and get it to seven games oh
we're watching the video when you got
thrown out from left field oh I hate I
hate bringing it up to no I love
bringing it up to you you love it you
later dad you love it so you stop you
get thrown out from left field at first
base it but you stopped oh yeah i mean
if if you if you get thrown out straight
left by hitting it to left and run you
have problems your real crop yes but i
did stop it's not sukriti caught it and
I was
I'm out and so I walk off store to walk
off crowd starts to rub and I'm like oh
my god Pablo zoodles picking it up to
the left so I just start and literally I
put my helmet back on like any smart
person would then I just start ice
skating I I like to look at the replay
like it was like I was ice-skating
quicksand I was like oh my god I can't
get out of the creeks and I had the
worst running tech I can't go to get my
legs won't move it was like when you
were in a dream yeah they're like
summary shake me like I can't move
that's what I fellow but it's a bang
bang play at first base though Sean oh
yeah it was bang bang it was bang bang
and i saw i saw i saw ron kulpa at a the
umpire at spring training this year this
year and i sent a move our warm shot of
jameson i said hey that's were calling
me out from our left thank you know what
I'm going to do I'm going to have Pauly
my producers send this to Major League
Baseball and I want them to rei want
them to review this on replay because i
think do you have a legitimate beef that
you could at least say look I was safe
and replay showed that because this this
wasn't reviewed and I think you may have
beaten that throw I think you may have
Shannon no dan I would really appreciate
that i'm not kidding could you get you
guys in that end okay i was thought that
too Paulie send that to MLB yeah they
got nothing else going on tonight so I
figured this will be pushing this
afternoon they can do it don't be busy
tonight we're on it boss okay all right
Sean I'll see what I can do for you Oh
Danny the Batman thanks buddy okay
thanks guys that's a Sean Casey major
league baseball Network Analyst we loved
his enthusiasm when he'd come into the
man cave man he would be all fired up
face all red he's the best he would just
be telling stories man he just said that
her tighter than Tito says to me man do
you have polio he's a great baseball
lingo guy to or you hit some middle you
know missile yeah Kern and whatever else
that's a great the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience